Росіяни зможуть стати громадянами України за спрощеною процедурою.
"Зелене світло" цьому дав президент Володимир Зеленський, підписавши відповідний указ.
Кому стане простіше отримати український паспорт, і які наслідки це матиме для України?
На українське громадянство за спрощеною процедурою зможуть претендувати росіяни,
які зазнали переслідувань у себе на батьківщині через політичні переконання.
А також загалом іноземці, які брали участь у бойових діях на Донбасі
та боронили Україну від збройної агресії Росії.
Указ Зеленського дозволяє їм не виходити зі свого громадянства, чого нині вимагає закон,
а лише відмовитися від нього, написавши відповідну заяву.
Втім, це лише перший крок.
Далі Кабмін має розробитивідповідний законопроект,
а парламент - проголосувати за нього.
Українські паспорти іноземним захисникам та опонентам путінського режиму
давав і п'ятий президент Петро Порошенко.
Приміром, торік таким чином громадянство набули майже тисяча вихідців з інших країн,
з-поміж яких 126 росіян.
Проте чимало добровольців та захисників України на синій паспорт іще чекають.
Тим часом новий господар Банкової лише за кілька місяців на посаді
вже встиг надати громадянство 23 іноземцям.
Здебільшого це безпосередні учасники бойових дій на Донбасі.
Указ Володимира Зеленського по суті став реакцією Києва на роздачу російських паспортів
на окупованих територіях на Донбасі.
Вкотре "рятувати росіян"Володимир Путін взявся одразу після другого туру президентських виборів -
у квітні,спростивши отримання громадянства для мешканців так званих "ДНР" та "ЛНР".
Згодом Кремль видав ще один указ -
тепер вже про паспорти РФ для усіх мешканців Донецької і Луганської областей,
ба більше - у Москві розмірковували і над поширенням спрощеного режиму набуття російського громадянства
на всіх українців.
Російські паспорти, за даними військової прокуратури України,
отримали вже 13 тисяч мешканців окупованих територій на Донбасі.
Тоді як загалом заявки на набуття громадянства РФ, як звітують у Москві,
подали близько 30 тисяч людей.
Ініціативу українського президента оглядачі оцінюють по-різному.
З одного боку указ може надати українське громадянство
навіть тим російським опозиціонерам, які підтримують анексію Криму та війну на Донбасі.
А це може дестабілізувати ситуацію в країні.
З іншого боку, указ Зеленського став успішною щонайменше піар-відповіддю Києва
на роздачу російських паспортів на сході України.
Великою проблемою є нереформованість Міграційної служби України та СБУ,
які часто відмовляли російським опозиціонерам в статусі біженців
і легко висилали в Росію або й навіть видавали їх ФСБ.
Тому оглядачі наполягають і на спрощенні процедур,
і водночас на чіткому механізмі перевірки кандидатів на отримання громадянства.
А також пропонують включити до урядових законопроектів
пряму заборону для учасників антиукраїнських політичних рухів.